that that's a trick question
because you know what the answer is to
that everyone in this life is more
interesting than mine you know I mean
that's everyone's life is to them it's
all it really is all relative but of
books of memoirs okay you know I'm
fascinated with well Edith Wharton then
House of Mirth what what I what
fascinated me by that book even though
it's not a memoir and I'm not quite
answering your question is that when you
when you read it now if you're you know
you can read it and you can say oh you
know this is kind of like a nastier Sex
in the City in a way in a way in a way
or some other kind of urban book that I
haven't read but then you realize that
this was written with ink and a piece of
bird and and the woman had to write it
in her head before putting it on paper
and and there was no there was no laptop
and it's complex book you know and that
that she would have been fascinating to
know fascinating to know Mark Twain
interests me he would have been a very
interesting person
oh okay no I can give you an answer I
have a better answer for you the person
that fascinates me is Emily Dickinson I
never cared about Emily Dickinson I grew
up in the same town I walked past that
house every day of my life my mother
loved Emily Dickinson I was not
interested at all
and then like two years ago
i I I picked up one of her the collected
poems and I picked it up and I just
started um looking at it and
really reading it and it was absolutely
astonishing as I'm the last to know
but what I find most astonishing is that
she was she was she didn't leave her
room you know she had a very very deep
sea of wisdom about so many features in
life and yet with her mind with her mind
alone which is interesting when you
think about it because don't they say
use 10% of our brains well if that's the
case that makes us very unique in nature
where the only wasteful thing right I
think we probably do use a hundred
percent of our brains but we don't know
what that other 90% does and Emily
Dickinson seemed to have been in touch
somehow with a lot more than she was in
touch with so I just find her
fascinating and I want that cookie
recipe